and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
begin with this question is there
anybody just anyone competent in the
bite Administration is anyone actually
working a full schedule the White House
called the lid again yet today at 4 pm
and we've barely heard from Joe Biden
all week certainly not during the
weekend even as our military is busy
shooting down unidentified foreign
objects out of the sky left and right
that Norad is saying might be
extraterrestrial now meanwhile on the
ground in East Palestine Ohio we have
toxic toxic chemicals pouring in the air
and the water killing animals and fish
causing locals to become ill after a
mass of what they call controlled burn
of the chemicals that can be seen from
miles on end our very own Sarah Carter
is live on the ground in Ohio she's been
with the people in the community all day
the situation is not good we'll hear
from her in just a moment but we should
really be hearing from the president of
the United States the White House it's
it's not a retirement home Joe being the
commander-in-chief is is not a life of
leisure so if Joe is unwilling or
incapable unable to work around the
clock and communicate with you the
American people uh he needs to get back
out back to Delaware fire up the heat to
hit it old blanket and retire there's no
excuse for Biden's lack of action and
there's no excuse for the American
people being kept in the dark when our
military is shooting down objects that
we can't even put a name to now tonight
we still have no idea what Biden shot
out of the sky this past weekend U.S
Intel officials now say that the objects
probably are not tied to the Chinese spy
balloon program okay so what does that
mean how would they know that why were
they shot down because none of it makes
sense and they have already been caught
lying to us and keeping us in the dark
so keep in mind none of the objects have
been recovered no private company no
foreign entity has claimed uh any
responsibility for them the U.S
government also denied ownership of
these unidentified objects and still
can't tell us or won't tell us what they
are Senator Mike Lee he received a
classified briefing today this is what
he tweeted quote I came away from the
briefing with more questions than
answers President Joe Biden's lack of
transparency is concerning and deeply
disturbing he continued it is unclear as
to whether these incidents are a series
of extremely significant events being
downplayed by the White House or
inconsequential incidents being
exaggerated and blown out of proportion
so did the administration shoot down
random debris with a half million dollar
missile to save face after the Chinese
spy balloon debacle or do we need to be
worried about our nation's security
don't we all deserve to know the answer
to these questions unfortunately it
appears that the White House thinks that
American sovereignty is just one big
political game or as Admiral Kirby
called it a balloon on the brain you
can't make it up take a look the
knowledge about the uh the balloon in
the track first came to our attention uh
last evening we haven't ruled anything
in or out um we and that that's why
we're calling this thing an object
um and you just called it a balloon you
misspoke there sorry it's not a yes I'm
sorry you guys have you can't say it's a
balloon you guys had me with a balloon
on the brain right now
[Music]
it was an object let me just clarify I'm
not classifying it as a balloon right
now it's an object we're still trying to
learn more from it
let me get this straight to shooting
three objects not necessarily balloons
out of the sky and they have no idea
what they shot down we invited John
Kirby on this program multiple times he
doesn't seem to want to answer our
questions or the administration maybe
they won't let him hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else